[Music]
hidey-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba who
are you hakuna matata Sally is here so
happy you can present your new
production company Hakuna Matata fellas
today we're going to watch this video
from looper one of my favorite channels
ever it's called this fan awesomely
reimagined The Lion King
characters The Lion King was a classic
animated film and then it's remake which
is almost the exact same movie made a
billion dollars in like three days
let's check this out and see if this
could have been any better are you ready
salamander Sally guys make sure it
follows Sally on YouTube Instagram
Twitter not pornhub despite what those
comments say or read it not read it
especially not read it especially not
read it but definitely porn up if you
let the theater feeling a little
disappointed by the Lion King remake one
fan artist has just the remedy for your
blues digital artist Taylor Thomas Young
soo is played by G JT theory and
director Jon Favreau's remake and he
doesn't just sound different either a
little exaggerated eye movements head
tilts winces and smiles that send
expressed in the 90's movie replaced
instead by a lion who looks real enough
to reach out and touch but is it really
as emotivist before
munchkin brought back said the signature
sass and his reworking of the characters
[Music]
looks out at the vast expanse of the
pride lands adult Simba also got a
retouch for Moscone who gave the remakes
version of the lion his orange tinged
main the eyes and expressive face was no
good really award-winning artist and
chart-topping singer-songwriter Beyonce
this time around
Simba's childhood friend heard Queen
Nala still wasn't perfect by motzkin's
estimations he made her brighter and
bluer her muzzle squarer and her eyes
larger and lower than before to son
biggest mistake the Lion King remake
made was dampening the medicine presence
of Simba's villainous uncle Scar voice
after she would tell Ejiofor known for
his work in films like 12 years a slave
and dr. strange did a pretty bang-up job
making scarce out as vicious as Jeremy
Irons did in the original Lion King but
most people felt that Disney's animators
failed to depict the meiji lion in all
his sinister wickedness
March can however aim to expect
he reimagined Scott McGreevy dark Sienna
coat yellow eyes and a scar that runs
down his forehead and cheek on top of
all that actually though it was marketed
as much Disney's live-action remake of
The Lion King wasn't actually
live-action at all
it certainly was a remake though
essentially taking the exact shots used
in the animated original and reimagining
them in photorealistic CGI animation the
end result was visually stunning but it
was also lacking a certain something
which many critics felt was the nuanced
emotion present in the 1994 version of
The Lion King talk about your
fixer-upper
the edits that Moscone created are sure
to appease the fans who might have found
themselves disappointed by the lion
Kings remake but they may also do
something better still motivate Disney
to hold off on just pumping out
live-action remakes of its classic
animated films and take a moment to
actually consider what the best approach
could be why would they do that like he
made a 595 million dollars worldwide as
of July 25th 2019 but box-office bucks
can only take a studio so far and if you
errs aren't joyously picking up what
it's putting down it might just be time
for Disney to figure out a plan to keep
its future live-action remakes from
getting hit with the same rotten reviews
that the Lion King did and if that never
happens well at least we got some cooler
at work out of it check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single fellow these guys what am
i complaints about the movie was what
they talked about in this video I don't
like in the film how animated those
voices are and yet the facial
expressions of the Lions in the movie
are going for such realism that the
voices often don't match so weirdly when
the film it was like the Lions don't
really work too well but other
characters like Timon and Pumbaa worked
really well because they have a likeness
with their enemy
even and the photo realism to be a
little bit more animated that adjusts
for the voices whereas the Lions don't
in theory
I like what I know you'd like looks like
realistic puppets so I could see like
how they just don't look real it looks
like they brought though these not real
types of lions to life I said so it
feels like really that's a good
comparison honestly I mean I would have
been more okay with them making them a
little more like not maybe not to this
extent because this is pretty it's
pretty cartoony and weirdly real so kind
of terrifying like imagine if they did
like for me what was missing from the
animation is the feeling it's a Disney
film The Lion King is from like the
Renaissance of Disney to have Aladdin
and then this and two completely
different tones yeah kind of weird you
know what's funny to me is like choose
the whoever the narrator is here she was
talking about how the Disney live-action
films like they need to reevaluate what
they're doing but I don't think they
will right now as we're filming this in
the the top five like a top five or six
highest-grossing movies of the year lion
king and alladin are in there and they
both made over a billion dollars he
doesn't care clearly it's working you
know whatever it is maybe critics don't
like it but the films are opening up to
a cinema scores that is a sign that the
audiences are enjoying it despite what
the critics are saying I like the Latin
I wasn't a big fan of Lion King because
liking was like there was too many
there's too many things I was liking the
animation and plus the fact they don't
try anything different was a little bit
annoying it was a little bit like
tedious I said I've had issues with
every live-action Disney film but I've
also taken things that I've liked about
it and
kind of like okay well I can always
watch the animated oh yeah that much but
with Aladdin at least they changed
enough to where it still kind of felt
like a different movie but everything
that you needed to be in there was in
there I feel like with the Lion King
maybe they could have changed up some
things you should have some storytelling
differences can you feel the love
tonight why was that during the day
because you need to be able to see what
was going on tonight isn't a song no I
never thought about that
that is very true I was look and I feel
like this was kind of the same idea well
yeah I mean I did like the jungle book
actually this story was fine I didn't
like the animation in it oh really
like I didn't like Baloo he looked so
gross it seems like the people I've been
responding so positively to the idea
that if they had done this with the The
Lion King animation and really changed
their faces look even more well this
would have felt honestly if they had
done this it might have felt even more
unnecessary to do this like what's the
point you just did a cartoon cuz I'm
like that looks like a cartoon it
doesn't look like a real animal
Oh Gabe does need credit for really just
going full throttle with the yeah not
geo animation that like pretty much
broke boundaries and CGI I feel like
which version would you guys have
prefered we do what they look like they
look like 3d versions of the 2d
animation that's what that looks like
this animatronic that's why it doesn't
look necessary yeah it doesn't look
necessary but then again the whole Lion
King movie wasn't all that necessary but
people loved it and I'm glad they do it
I still think I still gave it a
recommendation because on a visual
standpoint alone it was well worth
seeing in the theaters just for the
visuals and Timon and Pumbaa I will add
thanks for being here you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell follow salamander
Sallie on YouTube and Instagram I do you
should too I would like to give a patron
of the day shout out to someone very
special in my heart I want to give a
patient a shot to a man named Luke
Anderson Luke
and I used to have very long
conversations back and forth Luke and
for the past I want to say six months I
have mentioned every shoutout I've given
him that I haven't heard from him in six
months every month that goes by it's
another month that's being added on to
the fact that I haven't heard back from
it Luke and I like to give these very
personal shout outs and what happens if
I don't give a personal shoutout I
resort to insulting you as a way to
compensate for not having something kind
to say I go the exact opposite Luke
you're being kind of a jerk you're being
a dick reply back to me I really think
he just forgot his card is on file and
is getting automatically charged every
[Laughter]
point he's gonna call Wells Fargo like
what is this charge I've been getting
the past year you're not a jerk you're
not a dick you're a great guy he's
Friendly Ghost in you I know but he's
still given the real rejects of money so
you're okay I just need something to
fill the shoutout run time here you're
alright I love you buddy
you don't need to reply I don't care
here that would be nice imagine like he
doesn't comments wait who are you are
you guys are why are you taking my money